new guidance now from the cdc says fully
vaccinated people can
safely travel again within the u.s but
should still wear a mask
and social distance previously the
agency warned against
any unnecessary travel hector mahia now
live near mccarran airport today with
the latest on this new guidance hi
hector
hey there and the new update comes as
more people get vaccinated and evident
supports that fully vaccinated travelers
are less likely to get
and spread covet and this is major news
for the travel industry for mccarran for
cities like las vegas that have been
hardest hit by the pandemic
a person is considered fully vaccinated
two weeks after receiving the last
required dose
the new cdc guidance says domestic
travelers were fully vaccinated
no longer need to get tested unless it's
required by their destination
they also don't need to self quarantine
data suggests
vaccinated individuals do not transmit
the virus
we broke the news to travelers earlier
today it's spreading a lot of joy
but some are still urging caution
i think this is a sign that um good old
american ingenuity is doing its job
right now that's the most people i've
seen in a long time
in one place you know i mean you still
got to be careful
i pray that this
is the answer and that everything will
be open it's time for people
to see people again and
give me a warm feeling one fuzzy feeling
the u.s travel association issued a
written statement almost
immediately calling this a major step in
the right direction and added in part
quote
the year-long halt on travel has
devastated u.s employment
with travel supported jobs accounting
for 65 percent of all u.s jobs lost last
year
and this is an opportunity to begin
reclaiming a lot of what's been lost and
again this is only for domestic travel
unvaccinated people are still advised to
avoid
unnecessary travel reporting just
outside mccarran airport hector mejia
8 news now